you
[Music]
there have been many different things
written and said about marriage
from the sweetly inspirational to the
hilariously cynical but what many of
them have in common is that they sound
like they express a universal and
timeless truth when in fact nearly
everything about marriage from its main
purpose to the kinds of relationships it
covers to the rights and
responsibilities involved has vary
greatly between different eras cultures
and social classes so let's take a quick
look at the evolution of marriage
pair-bonding and raising children is as
old as humanity itself with the rise of
sedentary agricultural societies about
ten thousand years ago marriage was also
a way of securing rights to land and
property by designating children born
under certain circumstances as rightful
heirs as these societies became larger
and more complex marriage became not
just a matter between individuals and
families but also an official
institution governed by religious and
civil authorities and it was already
well established by 2100 BC when the
earliest surviving written laws in the
Mesopotamian code of ur-nammu provided
many specifics governing marriage from
punishments for adultery to the legal
status of children born to slaves many
ancient civilizations allowed some form
of multiple simultaneous marriage and
even today less than a quarter of the
world's hundreds of different cultures
prohibited but just because something
was allowed doesn't mean it was always
possible demographic realities as well
as the link between marriage and wealth
meant that even though rulers and elites
in ancient Mesopotamia Egypt and Israel
had multiple concubines or wives most
commoners could only afford one or two
tending towards monogamy in practice
in other places the tables were turned
and a woman could have multiple husbands
as in the Himalayan mountains we're all
brothers in a family marrying the same
woman kept the small amount of fertile
land from being constantly divided into
new households marriages could vary not
only in the number of people they
involved but the types of people as well
although the names and laws for such
arrangements may have differed publicly
recognized same-sex unions have popped
up in various civilizations throughout
history
Mesopotamian prayers included blessings
for such couples while Native American
two-spirit individuals had relationships
with both sexes the first instances of
such arrangements actually being called
marriage come from Rome where the
emperors Nero and Ella got us both
married men in public ceremonies with
the practice being explicitly banned in
342 ad but similar traditions survived
well into the Christian era such as
adelphic oasis or brother making in
Orthodox churches and even an actual
marriage between two men recorded in
1061 at a small chapel in Spain nor was
marriage even necessarily between two
living people ghost marriages were
either the bride or groom were deceased
were conducted in China to continue
family lineages or appease restless
spirits and some tribes in Sudan
maintained similar practices despite all
these differences a lot of marriages
throughout history did have one thing in
common with crucial matters like
property and reproduction at stake they
were way too important to depend on
young love especially among the upper
classes matches were often made by
families or rulers but even for
commoners who had some degree of choice
the main concern was practicality the
modern idea of marriage as being mainly
about love and companionship only
emerged in the last couple of centuries
with industrialization urbanization and
the growth of the middle class more
people became independent from large
extended families and were able to
support a new household on their own
encouraged by new ideas from the
Enlightenment people began to focus on
individual happiness and pursuits rather
than familial Duty or wealth and status
at least some of the time and this focus
on individual happiness soon led to
other trends
formations such as easing restrictions
on divorce and more people marrying at a
later age so as we continue to debate
the role and definition of marriage in
the modern world it might help to keep
in mind that marriage has always been
shaped by society and as a society
structure values and goals change over
time its ideas of marriage will continue
to change along with them